When we think of our modern-day,
successful entrepreneurs
and corporate leaders,
the thing they all have in common
is they excel at the general
cut and thrust of business:
outsmarting the competition,
growing the bottom line,
creating a superior product or service.
But to become a business rock star,
that rarefied category of a name
we all know and admire,
you need something else.
General good business acumen isn't enough.
The thing the rock stars
all have in common
is they disrupt business as usual.
They look at things the way they are,
and say to themselves,
"Nah, that's not it."
Consider how we used to search,
and how cumbersome the process was.
Sergey Brin and Larry Page
completely transformed the way
we find things and each other,
and even how we buy things.
And what about coffee?
For many of us, our morning brew
was a rather dull experience,
until Howard Schultz built Starbucks
for a community of people
who wanted fancy, varied, social coffee.
And of course, I can’t forget
Bill Gates and Steve Jobs:
two men who took computers
from nerdy labs and into our homes
and, in the case of Jobs, our palms too.
Now I know what some of you are thinking.
Don't worry, I will be coming
to that in a minute.
So if -- I know what you're thinking.
(Laughter)
So if innovators like these
can do all this,
then I believe they are up
for a new challenge.
A challenge that no one in business
has fully cracked yet.
So today, I want to talk to you
about why I think,
why I feel,
we need a rock star of inclusion.
The diversity and inclusion agenda
is one that most of us are sold on.
We know it boosts creativity and profits
and generally makes our lives richer.
We've known this for a very long time,
but if we're honest,
progress has been slow.
Nearly 90 percent
of Fortune 500 CEOs are white males.
And in the UK, where I'm from,
they account for 90.4 percent
of the top 20 roles in FTSE 100 companies.
Now that's the status quo
that is ripe for disruption.
Disruptors are not afraid
of doing the difficult.
They push through discomfort.
When others doubt, they see a better,
more exciting, new way --
a new way that others then emulate,
a new way that eventually
becomes the norm.
When it comes to diversity and inclusion,
we need bold disruptors
who are uncomfortable with the status quo,
even if the status quo benefits them --
in fact, especially
if the status quo benefits them.
Now the general thinking about DEI
is that we have to get comfortable
having uncomfortable conversations.
But there's a step before
that's often overlooked.
Before uncomfortable conversations
must come uncomfortable connections.
And that's something
I know a little about.
I get paid -- sometimes, anyway.
(Laughter)
I get paid to do the two things
that most people are uncomfortable doing:
public speaking and talking to strangers.
Now the thing is, when I was a kid,
my report card read "must talk less."
Luckily, I didn't listen.
So for the past 25 years,
I have been working in television --
first as an on-air talent,
more recently as an executive
focusing on DEI.
My work as a host has meant
that I've had to learn how to build
meaningful connections quickly,
with all kinds of people
from very different backgrounds.
But it hasn't always been easy.
There are neurological
and anthropological reasons
why we gravitate towards people
that remind us of ourselves.
There are unspoken codes of familiarity,
codes that make us feel safe.
We see this everywhere:
at conferences, lunch halls, parties,
even places of worship.
Now, there's a palpable feeling you get
when you don't connect with someone.
Don’t worry, I connect with you.
It's awkward, it's horrible,
and you just want it to be over.
But if you push through
to find common ground,
even if it's small,
just to get to the breakthrough,
that's when the magic happens,
and something changes in both people.
A game-changing moment came for me
early on in my career,
when I was interviewing a high-profile
actress, who shall remain nameless.
She was starring in a movie
that was considered
quite controversial at the time,
and as a result had been subjected
to countless insulting interviews.
So by the time I got round to her,
things were tense.
And to make matters worse,
we had absolutely nothing in common
to fall back on,
with her being
a high-profile A-list actress,
and me an up-and-coming host.
In that moment, I knew I had two choices.
One, to carry on as we were,
which would have been
very uncomfortable for us both,
and probably ended
in the interview being cut short.
Or two, try and find a breakthrough.
Now this was a well-seasoned actress,
and it wasn't a particularly
big-budget movie,
so I knew there had to be a bigger reason
as to why she'd accepted
the role in the first place.
So I decided to focus on the character,
rather than the controversy,
and she immediately opened up.
And we were able to have
a deep and thoughtful conversation
that was actually enjoyable for us both,
and she even thanked me at the end.
I learned so much from that encounter,
in terms of what can happen
when you don't give up
on an uncomfortable connection,
and how powerful
it can be for both people.
To this very day, that moment still serves
as a template for me
of what to do whenever I find myself
in a similar situation.
Now if we are to move society forward,
this is a journey we all have to make.
However, I believe
when it comes to the workplace,
those with the most power and agency
must make the biggest leap first.
Let me tell you about John Landgraf,
the CEO of FX.
In 2015, Variety magazine
wrote a scathing article
about the least diverse
networks in America,
in relation to directors.
And at the bottom
of what was a pretty bad list
was FX.
Out of the 168 episodes
that had aired on FX and FXX
between 2014 and 2015,
88 percent were directed by white men,
five percent by white women,
seven percent by men of color
and zero percent by women of color.
What happened next was interesting.
Instead of doing the usual corporate thing
of trying to defend the indefensible,
rather, Landgraf held up his hand
and pledged to diverse creatives
that he was going to act,
and act quickly at that.
So he and his team set about
putting together a concrete plan,
which included a significant
financial investment in diverse creatives
and in their suppliers,
to find, hire, nurture and develop
diverse creatives
from industries where there were
transferable skills,
such as music videos,
advertising and theater.
Within a year,
Landgraf had turned FX from being
the least diverse network in America
to one of the most.
And they had also managed to increase
their diverse directing pool
to just over half.
Critical and commercial
success would follow,
with hits such as "Atlanta"
and "Better Things."
And there would also be
an upsurge in paid subscriptions.
All because Landgraf
stopped following the crowd
and instead decided to disrupt
in an inclusive way.
I would call that
rock-star behavior, just saying.
(Laughs)
Now someone else that I think is already
a rock star in more ways than one
is Gareth Southgate,
the current England men's team
football manager.
Now before becoming England manager,
Southgate was a soccer player himself,
in the early 1990s and 2000s,
and witnessed firsthand the racist abuse
his colleagues of color were subjected to,
with monkey chants being screamed
at them during matches,
and banana peels thrown onto the pitch.
This searing knowledge
would serve Southgate well
when he became
the custodian of the careers
of a new generation of England players.
He knew he wanted to create
a better world for his players,
so he educated himself
on racial injustice,
and then did the same with the whole team,
by bringing in Owen Eastwood,
a New Zealand performance coach
whose modern-day interpretation
of the Māori philosophy, whakapapa --
"we are all connected,
therefore we all belong" --
would become embedded
in the psyches of the whole team.
Now, this England squad was like nothing
the country had ever seen before.
Vibrant with swagger --
as the young people would say --
ethnically diverse and aligned
to movements such as BLM.
So when American players,
led by Colin Kaepernick,
decided to take the knee,
Southgate’s players
did so too, in solidarity.
A public backlash ensued.
Rather than bow to public pressure,
Southgate penned
an open letter to the nation,
saying,
"I have a responsibility
to the wider community
to use my voice, and so do the players.
It's their duty to continue
to interact with the public
on matters such as equality,
inclusivity and racial injustice,
while using the power of their voices
to help put debates on the table,
raise awareness and educate."
There would soon be
another moment of truth.
When three of his Black players --
Marcus Rashford, Bukayo Saka
and Jadon Sancho --
missed their penalties
in the Euro's finals.
A barrage of torrid
racist abuse would follow.
Again, Southgate stepped up
and not only defended his players,
but took the blame, as coach.
And the beautiful thing that also happened
was, because of the education piece
that had gone before,
the whole team rallied around the players,
seeing an attack on one
as an attack on them all.
The unequivocal solidarity
that Gareth Southgate has been able
to create within this England team
is truly a profile in courage.
The level of emotional intelligence
and understanding
that he has displayed
means that he is now leading
one of the most unified sports teams
in modern times.
There's no reason this can't be
a template for business too.
There are hierarchies of inclusion
that exist in every society,
with those at the top on the inside,
and those at the bottom cast outside.
I grew up in London
as the daughter of African immigrants,
so I know what it feels like
to disrupt the world the way it is,
and to break through.
As a working-class Black woman,
somehow, I had
a different vision for myself
than the one the world had created for me.
Fortunately, we are now starting to see
more and more women of color progress.
But it shouldn't be on us.
Now I know many of you
will have noticed --
because I saw your faces,
I know you did --
that the list of business leaders
that I opened my talk with
were all white men.
And all white men from mainly
affluent backgrounds, at that.
That isn't a coincidence.
No one group has a monopoly
on talent or ability,
but as a result of the detrimental
impact of imperialism and colonialism,
up until very recently,
at least from a Western perspective,
this group has had a monopoly
on access and opportunity.
We are heading into some very turbulent
times economically,
and socially we’re at a crossroads, too.
In the past, difficult times
has often meant
that diversity and inclusion
have been put on a back burner.
I would argue now is the time
for us to dig deeper.
We know inclusion grows the bottom line,
and the leaders who truly understand this
will be the ones that not only win,
but win the right way.
So these innovators, these guys,
these rock stars
who have taken on everything
from computing, to commerce, to coffee --
wouldn't it be cool
to see them disrupt inequity too?
To look at the world the way it is,
just like Gareth and John did,
and say to themselves,
"Nah, that's not it."
I don't know about you,
but those are the kind
of rock stars I want to see.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)